in let me ask you how do did you always
know how to do impressions uh yeah I
guess I I did like I remember when I was
younger ice to do that's it that person
my first one you think girls I feel like
Michael Jackson for this popular girl
that I loved that was like how do you do
it my guys oh hey Michael
I can't even think of what yeah hey
Michael how was the recording thriller
yeah I would do the dance thing I would
do the whole thing whatever she needed
enough she wrote Michael Jackson Hunter
shoe and then one day she erased it and
it hurt my finger oh really I thought
like that was it
yeah are we over this did you get girls
back then no yeah we probably only got
girls as soon as you starting to stand
up huh uh probably like a little late
20s I started feel more comfortable mmm
but but yeah I was very non aggressive
mmm I like girls buttons in my head I
have a like a fancy but I missed a lot
of like Sciences one girl in college at
a party and I'm very focused on trying
to get some some action here you know
and this girls like you're coming home
with a may okay so you go in your head
oh I'm getting some action but me I'm
Michael but I don't she takes off all
their clothes except for panties gets in
bed she's like get in a bed with me so I
get in the bed I just lie there I did
nothing but anyway it's the game stops
stop yeah you didn't try anything no why
I honestly didn't think like I thought
it would be rude like I didn't think I
didn't see any of the signs and then I
like started that I liked her after and
then she was like oh
over me in terms of like she was like
you never did it then I didn't do it I
left this [ __ ] guy I know but but
roof over here what a [ __ ] loser
yeah oh man that's the worst out of all
the stories you've told I was that was
the most upset yeah yeah that's the most
upsetting one you bombed a bomb down
yeah yeah yeah there's a couple stories
like that I look back oh oh
were you always able to do the Trump on
a terrific yeah I didn't want to do I
don't want you to make it I know but
it's just so good that yeah yeah I've
actually been doing him for years and
years also when you want the presents
you're like ding ding yeah good but what
are the other impressions that you're
doing for year is that you people do you
really think oh very good yeah yeah but
did you know because a lot of
Impressionists that do the hacky once do
you do the hacking ones as well yeah
walkins a big one
what else is another if I see Joan
Rivers wow look at those people yeah
yeah De Niro is a big one right yeah
yeah I don't really do consider cover
either covered yeah they're covered yes
because Jeff Richards is very good as
well oh yeah yeah I love his Bill
O'Reilly Bill O'Reilly very good but
then there are some ones that he do that
you're just kind of like oh yeh it's
fine I'm trying to find new ones because
uh I just want I'm tellin who and who do
people want to stay in pop culture
yeah like Caitlyn Jenner people have
wanted to see right that's yeah that's
what else is something that's in Sapulpa
culture you know what like someone to
work on I'll work on it and then I'll
change that person and see if you think
it's that person what about like a like
a news person like that's like oh
Anderson Cooper would be hard
mmm-hmm I think that would be a broker
yeah yeah
then there's who's that Chris Cuomo is
that hard I haven't tried yeah but if
you can do a Chris Cuomo if you could
find it yes yeah that guy who did I
could do that guy who did the To Catch a
Predator
yeah oh here how about you Rachel have
his screen name was boner 95 yeah oh
yeah can we do that let's do I'm a pro
okay I want to be the pillar please let
me be the host
have a seat yeah what are you doing here
I know I was just in the neighborhood
and I um let me read your transcript
what you said yes I want to put my penis
yeah in your tiny [ __ ] you knew she
was 12 years old I was just testing it
out they say though I'm not testing it
out what does see if she you know and I
suppose this was you also testing it out
when you said I want to lick you all
over lol
[Music]